what do you do with duplicity I know
he's sitting there thinking he's the
number one Contender but in a month
we're gonna have Jemiah and Paulo Costa
they're going to come steal a lot of
Thunder they're going to get built up
I'm quite sure before that fight goes
off they're going to announce that this
is the number one contenders match and
it just feels as though the police is
going to need something to do and him
fighting without a Sonia not for a title
I love it what's the difference in many
ways what's the difference if they have
a problem with each other they never
said it was about the belt in the first
place they just want to fight the fight
still works they can still do it I agree
but if you're a duplicity's management
you know let's say is he needs a break
if you're duplicity's can you afford to
sit out and be out of the public eye for
seven months six months can the policies
afford that or does he take on a guy
like Canon there and stay active and
become undeniable